let's return to uh to still growth so
how did your path with this very
difficult very fascinating case uh cross
we were looking to open a case against
Tori because it was a problem all the
cases were closing uh because Tori so we
went on tour and we we came up with 26
Web different onion dot onions that we
targeted we were looking for nexuses to
hacking because I was on a squad called
cy2 and we were like the premier
um Squad in New York that was working uh
uh criminal cyber intrusions
and so you know any website that was
offering hackers for hire or
um hacking tools for free you know or
paid Services uh you know like now we're
seeing ransomware as a paid service and
phishing as a paid service
um anything that offered that so we
opened this case on on I think we called
it we so you have to name cases one of
the fun thing in the FBI is when you
start a case you get to name it you
would not believe how much time is spent
in coming up with the name yeah um you
know Casey goes by I think we called
this onion peeler because that's the
yeah so a little bit of humor a little
bit of wit and some profundity to the
language yeah yeah yes you're gonna have
to work with us for quite a lot so yeah
this one had the potential of being a
big one you know because I think I think
Silk Road was like the sixth on the list
uh for that case but we all knew that
was sort of the golden ring if you could
make the splash that that onion site was
going down then it would probably get
some publicity and that's part of you
know law enforcement is getting some
publicity out of of it that you know
that makes others think not to do it I
always just say that tour is the name of
the project the browser what is the
onion technology behind Tor let's say
you want to go to a dog onion site
you'll you'll put in the dot done you
want to go to and your computer will
build uh Communications with a tour
relay which are all publicly available
out there but you'll encrypt it you'll
put a package around your data and so
it's encrypted so can't read it it goes
to that that first relay that first
relay knows about you and then knows
about the next relay down the chain and
so it takes your data and then encrypts
that on the outside and sends it to
relay number two now relay number two
only knows about relay number one it
doesn't know who you are asking for this
and it goes through there adding those
layers on top layers of encryption so it
gets where it is that and then even the
onion service doesn't know except for
the the relay it came from who it's
talking to and so it peels back that
gives the information puts another layer
back on and so it's it's layers like
you're peeling an onion back of the
different relays and that encryption
protects uh who the sender is and what
information they're saying the more
layers there are the more exponentially
difficult it is to decrypt it
I mean you get to a place where you
don't have to have so many layers
because it doesn't matter anymore it's
mathematically impossible to decrypt it
but yeah um you know the more relays you
have the slower it is I mean that's one
of the big drawbacks on tour is is how
slow it operates
so how do you peel the onion
so what what are the different
methodologies for trying to get
some information from a cyber security
perspective on these operations like the
Silk Road it's very difficult people
have come up with different techniques
they're um there's been techniques to
put out in the in the news media about
how they do it um running like massive
amounts of relays and you're controlling
those relays I think I think somebody
tried that once so there's a technical
solution and and what about social
engineering what about trying to
infiltrate
the actual humans they're using
Nah The Silk Road and trying to get in
that way
yeah I mean I I definitely could see the
way of doing that and then in this case
uh in our takedown we use that
um there was one of my partners uh Jared
Dairy again he was an HSI investigator
and he had worked his way up to be a
system admin on the site
um so that did glean quite a bit of
information because he was he was inside
and talking to uh you know at that time
we only know it is DPR or dread pirate
Roberts we didn't know who who that was
yet but but we had that open
communication
um you know and one of the things you
know the technical aspects on that is
there was a jabber server that was uh
that's a communication type of
communication server
um that was being used and we knew that
Ross had his jabber set to Pacific time
so we had a pretty good idea what what
part of the we what part of the country
he was in
I mean isn't that from From dpr's
perspective from Russ's perspective
isn't that clumsy he wasn't a uh he
wasn't a big computer guy do you notice
that aspect of like the technical Savvy
of some of these guys doesn't seem to be
quite
why weren't they good at this well the
real techy Savvy ones we don't arrest we
don't get to them we don't find them
shout out to the techie uh criminals
they're probably watching this I mean
yeah I mean you were getting a
low-hanging fruit I mean we're getting
the ones that can be caught I mean they
you know I'm sure we'll talk about it
but the anonymous case there was a guy
named AV unit he still I lose sleep over
him because I we didn't catch him we
caught everybody else we didn't catch
him